vous l'avez peut-être aperçu ce matin un
dirigeable survolait le sud de la ville
de Tours et Tv Tours était à son bord il
s'agit du seul dirigeable à air chaud de
France après le survol de Chenonceau la
société Air Touraine va désormais
proposer des vols en dirigeables
au-dessus de la ville de Tours une
balade d'environ 20 minutes jusqu'à 200
mètres d'altitude le départ se fait au
parc de la gloriette la Turquie a testé
pour vous avec Clémence dosc
je suis au parc de la gloriette il a
encore tôt le matin le soleil n'est pas
encore levé et je m'apprête à faire un
tour en dirigeable mais la première
étape c'est le gonflage
[Musique]
après 45 minutes de préparation c'est
l'heure du décollage à bord de l'unique
dirigeable à air chaud de France
[Musique]
quelle notion de silence en fait on a
l'impression d'être
en survole en fait puis on a le ballon
au dessus de nous donc c'est assez joli
la différence avec la montgolfière c'est
là on peut se diriger et puis on a une
vue à 180 degrés 360 degrés enfin on
regarde partout donc c'est ça qui est
joli
[Musique]
le vol dure une vingtaine de minutes
c'est très fluide quand on est à
l'intérieur on a une vue sur toute la
ville de Tours et sur le parc de la
gloriette c'est un moment suspendu dans
l'air et dans le temps
40 mètres de long une vitesse de 25 km/h
maximum l'immersion est totale pour ce
premier départ de la saison le
dirigeable d'air Touraine peut
accueillir trois personnes en plus du
pilote et c'est levé jusqu'à 200 mètres
d'altitude le gros avantage c'est qu'on
peut aussi attirer toutes les personnes
handicapées les PMR les gens qui ont
beaucoup de difficultés à marcher
pourquoi parce que c'est quelque chose
qui vous est assis vous êtes attaché
c'est sur des pneus donc à
l'atterrissage c'est vraiment très très
doux on se pose vraiment sur des œufs on
ouvre la saison avec ce vol ce matin et
donc bon j'espère plein d'autres vols
cette année comptez 259 euros pour le
survol du sud de Tours et 289 au-dessus
de Chenonceau un prix pour une
expérience inédite à la recherche de son
public
[Musique]